[Musik]
und jetzt das sollte schon mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka guten abend bei
einem blick aufs kriegsgeschehen
beginnen wir heute mit dem blick auf den
wirtschaftskrieg der parallel zu den
ukrainischen schlachtfeldern im gange
ist zwischen russland und dem westen
da gibt es interessante entwicklungen
zum einen hat bundeskanzler scholz mit
wladimir putin telefoniert der in dem
gespräch offenbar zu verstehen gab dass
das mit dem sofortigen umstieg bei gas
käufen auf rubel wohl doch nicht so
eilig ist eigentlich sollte das ja ab
freitag gelten wirtschaftsminister
habeck hatte deshalb heute schon
vorsorglich die erste stufe des
sogenannten notfallplan gas aktiviert
dazu gleich ein gespräch mit ihnen auch
zu forderungen nach einem energie
embargo gegen russland zuvor der bericht
von tadeusz parat
hier in der friedrich wilhelms hütte in
mülheim an der ruhr wird stahl in
höchster qualität für maßgeschneiderte
bauteile produziert über die hohen
gaspreise echten sie schon jetzt ein gas
lieferstopp aber wäre nicht zu
verkraften
der energieversorgung besteht aus gas
und dieses gas können wir nicht
substituiert daher wäre eine einstellung
der gasversorgung mit einem sofortigen
betriebsstillstand verbunden nicht nur
die stahlindustrie ist alarmiert auch
die chemiebranche der weltweit größte
chemiekonzern basf in ludwigshafen
könnte ohne gas gezwungen sein den
betrieb einzustellen
bislang nur theorie doch angesichts der
angespannten situation auf dem gasmarkt
zieht der bundeswirtschaftsminister
konsequenzen um für diese situation
vorbereitet zu sein habe ich heute
morgen die frühwarn stufe nach der gas
verordnung ausgerufen die frühe
warnstufe ist die erste stufe von drei
möglichen stufen drei eskalationsstufen
mit unterschiedlich tiefen eingriffen
dramatisch wird es bei stufe 3
spätestens dann würde die
bundesnetzagentur komplett regie
übernehmen und zwangsmaßnahmen anordnen
stilllegungen von gaskraftwerken sind
eine option abschaltungen für gas
intensive industrie eine weitere erst am
ende beträfe es privathaushalte
krankenhäuser und soziale einrichtungen
denn sie stehen unter besonderem schutz
die folgen eines solchen szenarios
preise würden sich weiter verteuern die
inflationsrate noch höher steigen auch
die gesamtwirtschaftlichen verwerfungen
wären gravierend in welchem ausmaß
darüber streiten ökonomen ein russischer
gas lieferstopp sei verkraftbar sagt das
eine lager das fängt damit an möglichst
jetzt sofort alle von sichtbare gasthof
einzustellen und das gas lieber einzeln
speicher sich in der industrie zum teil
nicht deutsche nicht europäische
zulieferer zu suchen die energieintensiv
hergestellt vorprodukte daneben auch bei
einem ausfall russischen gases weiter
produzieren können das andere lager
sieht solche berechnungsmodelle kritisch
hier kommen zu dem ergebnis dass
wenn es zu einem lieferstopp käme bei
russischer energie die deutsche
wirtschaft in eine tiefe rezession
stürzen würde die deutsche wirtschaft
würde im industriellen kern getroffen
und sie würde
in einer situation getroffen in der sie
sich noch nicht von der krise
erholt hat gas nur noch gegen rubel
diese drohung scheint der kreml nun
nicht mehr verfolgen zu wollen und
sicherte der bundesregierung zu dass sie
weiter in euro zahlen kann derweil gibt
es in moskau offenbar neue
gedankenspiele rubel zahlungen für
metalle wie zb aluminium
gedankenspiele die man in der friedrich
wilhelms hütte mit großem unbehagen
aufnimmt
der bundeswirtschaftsminister ist uns
zugeschaltet guten abend der weg
nur mit grüßen gab heute zwei
interessante entwicklung ihres ur
betreffen zum einen haben sie die erste
stufe des notfallplan gas das ist eine
vorsorge
aktiviert zugleich gab es das gespräch
von bundeskanzler mit dem kreml bei dem
mann dann offenbar den eindruck hat so
eilig haben es die russen jetzt doch
nicht mit der umstellung auf rubelbasis
interpretieren sie das wie schätzen sie
das ein
ja die situation ist schwer zu lesen und
die aussagen sind manchmal nicht ganz
eindeutig aber umso wichtiger ist es
dass wir uns für alle eventualitäten
wappnen der fahrplan ist ja so dass
morgen angekündigt ist dass die
russische regierung die putin regierung
ein gesetz vorlegen wird aus dem dann
hervorgeht ab wann mit rubel bezahlt
werden soll und für welche güter also
man muss da wohl ein bisschen auch das
kleingedruckte achten so scheint sich
der tag zu deuteln aber wir wissen eben
nicht genau was es dann bedeutet in der
lieferung und deswegen haben wir heute
diese früh warnstufe ausgerufen ein
monitoring system wird jetzt aufgebaut
und zwar verpflichtend aufgebaut wir
haben natürlich die ganzen letzten
monate schon den gas und öl markt
monitor aber jetzt gibt es sozusagen
berichtspflichten der betreiber der
gasleitung unternehmen
noch mal auf die russen zurück zu kommen
dass dies jetzt dann doch nicht so eilig
haben mit der umstellung auf rubel oder
ihrerseits den gashahn der ölhahn
zuzudrehen
wenn man aber schon auch so
interpretieren dass es da offenbar ein
großes interesse daran gibt dass diese
lieferung weiterlaufen auf russischer
seite ja ich würde noch nicht so weit
gehen dass das jetzt
der koordinierte rückzug von der drohung
ist denn wir haben gesehen dass auch der
krieg in der ukraine selbst eigentlich
keinen sinn macht und trotzdem ist er
geführt worden also wir sind hoch alert
und beobachten die situation sehr genau
und arbeiten dann mit kräften daran dass
wir auch eine schwierige situation gut
bestehen können also haben das gas
speicher gesetz durch den bundestag
gebracht die speicherstände fühlen sich
mit jedem tag ein bisschen wir bauen die
erneuerbare energien aus lng terminals
all das ist schon häufig gesprochen
worden also es gibt keinen grund sich
zurückzuziehen oder irgendwie entspannt
auf die situation zu schauen aber es ist
richtig es gibt signale die sagen nicht
sofort und nicht so schnell und
das kann eben auch ein zeichen sein dass
die große geschlossenheit die
g7-minister haben darauf ja sehr schnell
und sehr klar geantwortet dann durchaus
auch seinen effekt hat ich frage auch
deshalb weil sie wissen die forderungen
jetzt wirklich einen kompletten
importstopp zu machen also ein richtiges
embargo und sich vom gas und
öllieferungen aus russland sofort zu
verabschieden um ebendiese
kriegsmaschinerie auch nicht länger mit
täglich hunderte millionen euro zu
finanzieren diese forderungen werden ja
lauter
na ja die sind ja von anfang an da also
ich jedenfalls habe die ganze zeit
gehörten tauchen diese in diesem aufruf
der von vielen prominenten
wissenschaftlern unterschrieben wurde
und auch zum teil von politikern es gibt
ökonomen die modellrechnungen vorgelegt
haben die hat der bundeskanzler am
sonntag bei der kollegin will so
abgebügelt als unverantwortliche
rechnerei haben sie dann ähnliches
verhältnis zur wirtschaftswissenschaft
oder sehen sie sich die etwas genauer an
wir haben das heute noch mal intensiv
mit den wissenschaftlern diskutiert ich
würde sagen das ist natürlich möglich
ist aus bestimmten erfahrung welche
modellrechnungen anzustellen wie im
moment ich persönlich mein team aber
versuchen die physik der transporte zu
durchdringen und zu reparieren uns
darauf vorzubereiten also hier ist
physik und technik und hier sind die
modellrechnungen und die ergebnisse sind
durchaus unterschiedlich
ein durchschnittlicher verlust von
wachstum sagt eben nichts dazu ob
bestimmte gas ströme oder öl ströme
bestimmter regionen erreichen und dann
ist das durch die
durchschnittsberechnung am ende nicht
aussagekräftig wir zählen lkws wir
suchen kesselwagen wir versuchen die
drucksysteme in den pipelines auf euch
zu erhalten wir versuchen die pumps
system versehen und dann hat das eben
nichts mehr mit durchschnitts rechnung
zu tun also wir gehen da unterschiedlich
ran wir haben aber auch unterschiedliche
aufgaben ich musste energiesicherheit in
deutschland am ende garantieren das
müssen die anderen kollegen nicht es
gibt aber natürlich auch politische
kosten die deutschland hat wenn wir als
das land da stehen das quasi sich vor
allem für seine eigenen rechnungen und
seine eigene wirtschaft interessiert
wären da ein furchtbarer abschlachten in
unserer nachbarschaft stattfindet das
argument nämlich ernst aber ich
beobachte dass es genau andersrum sich
auflöst wir tun ja nicht nichts sondern
wir bereiten die schritte gut vor und
wir gehen sie dann wir haben es in den
letzten vier wochen nur vier wochen
geschafft die energieimporte von
russland deutlich zu reduzieren
heute hat polen ein land das sehr häufig
gesagt hat sofort im wago gesagt wir
wollen bis ende 2022 unabhängig von
russischem öl und kohle seien ja wir
sind schneller aber das ist ja immerhin
der gleiche weg also auf einmal nähern
sich
weiter das ist ja das warum auch die
ukraine sagt hört auf damit dann wird
auch putin sehr viel schneller aufhören
würde ich sagen weil die rubel forderung
von putin ja im grunde ausdruck dessen
ist das richtigerweise die öl und gas
lieferung ja bezahlt werden mit dem geld
aber nicht viel anfangen kann warum
nicht weil die zentralbank sanktioniert
ist das heißt die ganz kurze aussage wir
finanzieren den krieg dies eigentlich
gar nicht richtig wir finanzieren das
russische staat system in der
abstraktion das ist richtig und das ist
schlimm und bitter genug und insofern
arbeiten wir daran daran dass auch zu
beenden aber das geld das wir überweisen
wird nicht im panzer verbaut sondern
liegt bei der zentralbank die damit
nicht arbeiten kann das ist ja dass
deswegen sagt jetzt müsst ihr in rubel
bezahlen damit ich mit dem geld was
anfangen und meinen staat der eigentlich
bankrott ist finanzieren können dann
dürfte man sich eigentlich auch nicht
darauf einlassen was putin der heute vor
schlug ihr bezahlt weiterhin euro und
wir tauschen dann um eine frage noch zum
schluss haben wir haben heute diese
meldung bekommen 7,3 prozent inflation
dass die inflationsrate seit 40 jahren
ist das schon ein vorbote dass der
kriegsfolgen oder ist das noch nach der
pandemie weil wir sind quasi
kriegspartei als wirtschafts
kriegspartei und wir zahlen auch einen
preis der ist natürlich nichts
verglichen mit dem preis den preis nie
die ukrainer zahlen sie sterben sie
werden vertrieben sie werden ausgebombt
wir haben eine hohe inflation aber ein
preis ist es natürlich auch es ist ein
externer schock der auf das land kommt
und das muss man so klar sagen wir
werden dadurch ärmer werden dass die
gesellschaft wird es tragen müssen die
frage wird beantwortet werden müssen wie
wir das gerecht verteilen wie viel wir
über schulden strecken und an späteren
generationen zur tilgung der schulden
übertragen aber dass das ohne kosten für
die deutsche gesellschaft ausgeht ist
nicht möglich es ist nicht denkbar das
sehen wir jetzt aber ich glaube und ich
bin mir eigentlich sicher dass wir
bereit sind diesen preis zu zahlen er
ist ja gegenüber dem leiden in der
ukraine klein genug wir müssen es nur so
organisieren dass nicht die schwächsten
der gesellschaft die ärmsten dann auf
den hohen kosten für sicherungen kosten
sitzen bleiben sagt der
bundeswirtschaftsminister herbig
hinterlässt gespräch ich danke ihnen
das interview haben wir vor einer stunde
geführt der wahl geht das bombardieren
und sterben in der ukraine weiter die
skeptiker die gestern schon davor
warnten die russischen ankündigungen
über einen teilweisen truppenrückzug für
allzu bare münze zu nehmen sehen sich
heute eher bestätigt weder in kiew noch
in der stadt terni verlief die nacht
ruhiger als zuvor heulende sirenen und
zahlreiche einschläge eine deeskalation
oder vertrauensbildende maßnahme von der
die russische seite gestern sprach
stellt man sich anders vor oliver
reichert berichtet
diese markthalle in chania fest in der
nacht ziel russische angriffe trotz der
ankündigung russlands die
militäraktivitäten im norden der ukraine
radikal zu verringern
der feind hat diese reduzierung
militärische aktivitäten dadurch
demonstriert dass er unsere region aus
der luft angegriffen und die ganze nacht
nef getroffen hat
aus der umgebung von jenny 11 seien noch
gar keine truppen abgezogen worden sagte
ukrainische seite der präsident beklagt
den fortgang des krieges
wo auch der feind ist immer noch auf
unserem territorium der beschuss unserer
städte geht weiter europolis blockiert
die raketen und luftangriffe hören nicht
auf
aus der gegend von kiew allerdings zögen
wirklich einige russische verbände ab
bestätigen die ukraine wie auch die usa
also been some bogen gab es gestern
einen rückzug von einheiten war hier das
denken wir in geringem umfang aber wir
glauben es ist eine neuaufstellung kein
richtiger rückzug wir sollten auf eine
grossoffensive in anderen gegenden der
ukraine vorbereitet sein
alpin ist ein vorort von kiew wurde am
montag von ukrainischen truppen
zurückerobert
zurück bleibt ein bild der zerstörung
der bürgermeister von erb ihn berichtet
heute von hunderten toten
ich glaube ungefähr 200 300 menschen
sind leider getötet wurden sehr viel ist
unter den trümmern 50 der stadt und der
kritischen infrastruktur sind zerstört
die überlebenden berichten von
kriegsverbrechen der russen von
brutalität von vergewaltigungen
sie haben einfach männer auf der straße
erschossen russische soldaten haben
zivilisten gezwungen sich auszuziehen
männer wie frauen sie haben sie in eine
reihe gestellt geschlagen und gedemütigt
was hier in europa geschah ermittler
sollen es jetzt überprüfen
zum krieg in der ukraine gibt es nachher
im heute-journal update noch ein
gespräch mit
bundesverteidigungsministerium lamprecht
und jetzt macht erstmal heinz wolf
weiter den nachrichten
mecklenburg-vorpommerns
ministerpräsident in manuela schwesig
ist nach sechswöchiger krankheitspause
zurück im amt sie hat eingeräumt dass
ihre jahrelange unterstützung von nord
stream 2 ein fehler gewesen sei auch die
gründung der klimaschutz stiftung
mecklenburg vorpommern die 20 millionen
euro von nord stream zwei geflossen sind
sei aus heutiger sicht falsch sagte
schwesig in schwerin es sei gut dass
nord stream 2 0 gestoppt sei die
stiftung werde abgewickelt so die
ministerpräsidentin
bundesarbeitsminister heil hat heute mit
arbeitgebern sozialverbänden und
gewerkschaften über eine
integrationsstrategie für die
ukrainischen flüchtlinge beraten neben
der gesellschaftlichen eingliederung
ging es vor allem um eine rasche
einbindung in den arbeitsmarkt heil
sprach sich unter anderem für eine
schnellere anerkennung von
qualifikationen aus
kerstin klaus wirth neue unabhängige
beauftragte für fragen des sexuellen
kindesmissbrauchs der bundesregierung
sie wird nachfolgerin von johannes
wilhelm röhrig der das amt ende februar
abgegeben hatte die journalistin war
2015 in den beiden
missbrauchsbeauftragten angesiedelten
betroffenen rat berufen worden
bundesfamilienministerin spiegel
erklärte bei der gemeinsamen
pressekonferenz noch in diesem jahr
solle es eine aufklärungskampagne zu
kindesmissbrauch geben
pflegekräfte in kliniken und
pflegeheimen sollen für ihren einsatz
während der korona pandemie einen pflege
bonus erhalten er wird gestaffelt nach
der jeweiligen tätigkeit und reicht von
bis zu 370 euro bis etwa
2500 euro das bundeskabinett
verabschiedete einen entsprechenden
gesetzentwurf von gesundheitsminister
lauterbach wie er sagte sollen mehr als
1 5 millionen beschäftigte einen bonus
erhalten
zu den aktuellen coroner zahlen das
robert koch institut meldet
1477 neuinfektionen innerhalb eines
tages das sind 15 1255 weniger als vor
einer woche
348 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incident sinkt leicht auf
wieder mehr als 300 tote also wäre der
krieg nicht würde das krone thema
vermutlich mehr raum einnehmen und zu
noch schärferen debatten führen am
samstag laufen ja die übergangsregeln
bei den schutzmaßnahmen endgültig aus
etwa die masken pflicht den innenräumen
die bis jetzt noch als ein
dämmungsmaßnahmen aufrechterhalten wurde
die fdp wollte das auch das entfällt
unabhängig von den instituten jenen
bundesländern denen das zu riskant ist
die steigende krankenhaus belegungen
registrieren und fürchten dass ihnen das
aus dem ruder läuft bleibt jetzt nur
sich zum corona hotspot zu erklären
bisher hatte das nur
mecklenburg-vorpommern getan heute zieht
hamburg nach das ist wohl auch ein
juristischer tests martinis berichtet
draußen auf dem jungfernstieg gilt die
masken pflicht schon lange nicht mehr
und drinnen in den geschäften würde sie
nach dem neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz am samstag fallen
doch in hamburg muss dort vier weitere
wochen einen mund nasen schutz getragen
werden um einer überlastung des
gesundheitssystems vorzubeugen erklärte
die bürgerschaft die hansestadt zum
hotspot das gesetzlich ausdrücklich vor
dass wenn absehbar ist dass
infektionszahlen steigen und diese
situation haben wir seit einer woche wir
maßnahmen ergreifen sollen um das
infektionsgeschehen abzumildern
das in corona fragen als besonders
vorsichtig geltende hamburg folgt damit
dem beispiel mecklenburg vorpommerns in
niedersachsen gilt ab dem wochenende
trotz deutlich höherer fallzahlen nur
der sogenannte basisschutz obwohl eine
masken pflicht beim einkaufen und
größeren veranstaltungen auch weiterhin
sinnvoll gewesen wäre so die
gesundheitsministerin
unsere intensivbetten sind gut
eingestellt wir können alle cupid 19
patienten patienten gut versorgen und
daher können wir diese hohen auflagen
die der bundesgesetzgeber uns für eine
hotspot regelung im grunde vorschreibt
nicht erfüllen ähnlich interpretiert
baden württemberg das
infektionsschutzgesetz es sehe keine
prophylaktischen maßnahmen vor
kritisiert der ministerpräsident
wenn das alles ein kriegt was jetzt im
gesetz steht dann ist es natürlich zu
spät wenn man erst dann an den an aber
vorher könige nicht handeln das heißt
wir halten uns an die gesetze des bundes
unterhalten uns auch an schlechte
gesetze der zuständige bundesminister
hält die kritik an dem gesetz für
ungerechtfertigt und kalt zurück
drohende gefahr einer überlastung des
gesundheitswesens ist begründbar da bin
ich fest davon überzeugt dass die
regelungen in mecklenburg vorpommern und
auch in hamburg also rechtlich bestand
haben werden ich finde es
beklagenswert und falsch da sehr viele
bundesländer wo ich selbst also eine
solche regelung also für angemessen
befunden hätte dass diese länder davon
nicht gebrauch machen bislang machen
aber eben nur zwei von 16 bundesländern
von der regelung gebrauch ob sie
tatsächlich bestand hat will die fdp die
im bund das gesetz mitgestaltet hat in
hamburg nun gerichtlich klären lassen
dass in hamburg absolut nicht notwendig
ein hotspot einzurichten
die hotspot regelung sie darf nur
gezogen werden wenn eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems droht das in hamburg
überhaupt nicht der fall viel streit
also in dem es am ende nur darum geht
angesichts hoher infektionsraten vier
weitere wochen maske zu tragen
und jetzt nochmal heinz mit dem blick
auf die wirtschaft die aussichten der
deutschen wirtschaft und die schon
angesprochene inflation waren heute
natürlich auch themen für die börse war
der reha ist dort für uns lassen sie uns
zuerst noch mal genauer auf die
inflation schauen ja also mit mehr
inflation hat man hier schon gerechnet
dass sie aber so hoch ausfällt das hat
die börsenprofis dann doch überrascht
zuletzt wurde so ein wert schließlich
vor 40 jahren erreicht preistreiber
waren auch diesmal teures öl und gas der
ukraine krieg hat die lage noch mal
verschärft um 7,3 prozent dass die
inflationsrate gestiegen im vergleich
zum vorjahr ein riesensprung im februar
hatte sie noch bei 5,1 prozent gelegen
und das ist vielleicht noch nicht das
ende der fahnenstange der
sachverständigenrat der bundesregierung
schließt auch eine zweistellige
inflationsrate dieses jahr nicht mehr
aus vor allem wenn es zu einem stopp von
russischen energielieferungen kommt dann
bestünde auch ein substanzielles risiko
für eine rezession aber auch ohne
lieferstopp müsse man mit dauerhaft
höheren energiepreisen rechnen die
inflation und der ukraine krieg sagen
die wirtschaftsweisen belasten die
konjunktur schwer und stutzen deswegen
ihre jahresprognose dieses jahr rechnen
die wirtschaftsweisen mit 1,8 prozent
wachstum im november waren es noch 4,6
prozent deutlich besser das kommende
plus 3,6 prozent konjunktursorgen
setzten auch der börse zu der dax heute
tief im minus mit knapp 1,5 prozent
gestern noch glaubte man hier an
fortschritte bei den
ukrainisch-russischen verhandlungen doch
die hoffnungen waren heute erstmal dahin
valerie haller vielen dank
im osten australiens haben erneut
tausende menschen ihre häuser nach
starken unwetter verlassen müssen die
behörden ordneten in den besonders
betroffenen regionen evakuierungen an
bereits das zweite mal in diesem monat
seit montag hatte es heftig geregnet in
manchen gegenden bis zu 420 millimeter
pro tag die böden sind nach wochenlangen
extremwetter in völlig aufgeweicht und
dadurch steigt die gefahr von
erdrutschen und sturzfluten
zurück nach deutschland und zu den
zahlen vom lotto am mittwoch sie lauten
wie immer ohne gewähr
die gewinnzahlen lauten da kommen sie 6
12 13 27 34 41 superzahl 3 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
wir wissen nicht ob und was an bord der
internationalen raumstation iss über den
ukraine krieg gesprochen wurde entgangen
ist in astronauten und kosmonauten das
weltgeschehen aber natürlich nicht zumal
plötzlich die frage im raum stand ob die
russen den amerikaner mark wenn der herr
mit zurück zur erde nehmen das haben sie
getan die sojus kapsel landete sicher in
der kasachischen steppe und der us
astronaut wurde von der russischen
raumfahrtbehörde freundlich begrüßt
willkommen zurück mark tonlage war
zwischenzeitlich aber auch schon mal
eine andere so seine freitag berichtet
touch stern die crew ist und gelandet in
kasachstan russen der amerikaner marc
van dabei war
355 tage am stück im all ein rekord
seine beiden kollegen sind russische
kosmonauten eigentlich normal aber es
ist krieg hier auf der erde
oben auf der iss hatte anton stapler of
gestern symbolisch den schlüssel an den
amerikaner thomas marshburn übergeben
kappelhoff ist auf der krim geboren die
botschaft eindeutig die
probleme und die menschen haben probleme
auf der erde aber hier im orbit sind wir
eine mannschaft
ich denke die iss ist ein symbol der
freundschaft und der kooperation
amerikaner russen und der deutsche
matthias maurer waren schon oben als der
krieg ausbrach
wie sie darüber denken wird sorgfältig
von der öffentlichkeit ferngehalten denn
das all wird zum politischen druckmittel
dimitri rogosin chef der russischen
raumfahrtbehörde
drohte die iss abstürzen zu lassen er
pustete ein video in dem der amerikaner
van der heide allein im all
zurückgelassen wird dann stürzt die
raumstation kommen jan wörner kennt
rogosin gut er war esa chef während der
krim krise bisher sind wir immer
außerhalb dieser geopolitischen
streitereien gewesen und deshalb habe
ich in den letzten wochen das wirklich
immer kritischer gesehen und immer auch
mehr und mehr bedauert dass
offensichtlich dass man die sanktionen
an der raumfahrt nicht vorbeigehen die
esa sagte die russisch europäische
forschungs mission exomars ab ein teures
prestigeprojekt auf eis gelegt matthias
maurer stieg vor einer woche aus der
raumstation aus zu wartungsarbeiten auf
der erde betreuen ihn die
wissenschaftler im deutschen institut
für luft- und raumfahrt dlr
auch dort hat man die kooperation mit
russland eingestellt gemeinsame
experimente sind betroffen trotzdem
arbeiten die astronauten auf der
raumstation weiter zusammen letzten
endes sitzen die da oben in einem boot
ja und die isaf niemand kann die alleine
kontrollieren oder steuern und dies ist
abhängig und die wollen zusammenarbeiten
und zum wohle der erde zum wohle der
gesellschaft experimente machen die
neuen russischen kosmonauten kamen
kürzlich in blau gelben raumanzügen an
das seien die farben der technischen uni
in moskau hieß es zufall oder statement
jedenfalls wurde der amerikaner marc van
de heute nicht allein an bord
zurückgelassen und die iss ist immer
noch oben aber zum ersten mal wurde die
kooperation im weltall ernsthaft aufs
spiel gesetzt
tja das war ja auch schon im kalten
krieg so dass der auch im weltall
geführt wurde wir sind am ende des
heute-journals die kollegen vom
auslandsjournal machen weiter auch mit
reportagen aus der ukraine und um 0.30
gibt es dann unser heute-journal update
mit christopher wehrmann mit uns gibt's
morgen wieder auf wiedersehen
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon gut ab und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter der märz ist nun fast vorbei und
es war der sonnenschein reister seit
der hat sogar den mittelwert das
langjährige mittel des julis übertroffen
und wir schauen auch auf die trockenheit
ist auch eine sehr trockene phase und
über die jahrzehnte hinweg hat die
trockenheit vor allem im frühling immer
weiter zugenommen und wenn sie hier auf
die letzte karte schauen vor allem im
osten wird es immer trockener die
trockenheit hat jetzt erst einmal eine
pause ist kommt arktische kaltluft und
in dieser art tischen kaltluft hat sich
ein kleines tief gebildet das bringt
schnee vor allem schon mal im nordwesten
deutschlands in der nacht wird sich hier
eine schneedecke wahrscheinlich
ausbilden und regen ist auch dabei im
süden ebenfalls sonst ist es trocken bei
tiefsten temperaturen von minus zwei
grad im osten deutschlands häufig werde
um die null grad marke im norden und 7
grad plus im südwesten morgen dann
weitere schneefälle im nordwesten
deutschlands teilweise kräftiger
nordwestwind und dieser schnee setzt
sich weiter in die westlichen
mittelgebirge durch im süden regnet es
im osten merkt man kaum etwas davon hier
scheint die sonne die höchsten
temperaturen dazu zwei grad gerade mal
an der nordsee sonst im süden elf grad
das wäre die temperaturspanne am freitag
dann vor allem in der mitte ergiebige
schneefälle hier kann sich sogar im
flachland dann eine schneedecke
ausbilden bei temperaturen von null bis
sieben grad und den darauf folgenden
tagen lässt der schnee ganz langsam nach
ein schöner abend